if we don't get up and fight for our
city nobody's coming for us the other
place that this is happening at a crazy
rate is New York City and we covered
over the last two weeks how Eric Adams
the mayor of New York City who is a
leftist buffoon although he wears
well-tailored suits that's nice Ellie
he's no fetterman in that regard his his
suits do fit well but he has let in 10
000 people a month the city is being
overrun they are putting uh instead of
having tourists in hotels that's the way
it used to be in the greatest city in
the world they are over running hotels
the Roosevelt Hotel which is one of the
most legendary hotels literally in the
world certainly was one of the top three
hotels in New York City for decades is
now basically a mass migrant shelter and
the people of New York City have had it
check this out from Fox
I had to spend time hundreds of dollars
to get their school supplies
they're coming here not vaccinated we
just had a coveted crisis they shut our
businesses down yes they fired teachers
fire department for not getting
vaccinated who do you think needs to do
more we hear from the mayor of New York
who says he's doing everything it can
every day as migrants continue to come
in we are we are I will say too we're
live on air so but you know what do you
think about what the mayor's doing and
what should the president and the White
House be doing
this is up to us this is up to each and
every one of us to stand up nobody's
coming here for us right we're here for
ourselves if we don't get up and fight
for our city nobody's coming for us
they're coming and destroy it the reason
why they're here is to steal our votes
that that is a good man
um I have no doubt The Machine's gonna
probably come after him and he'll you
know someone will try to get him fired
from his job if anyone knows who he is
if there's anything I can do to help him
I mean I feel for that I lived in that
City for 20 years I love that City I've
told you guys many times and I've
written about in my books there were
times in New York City Manhattan in the
boroughs that my family had upwards of
like 60 70 people living in New York
City
um there's one I got one cousin left as
far as I know uh because everybody has
fled the last ones to flee were my my
sister and brother and their three kids
now live in in the Free State of Florida
surprise surprise uh when he says that
no one's come and help him he's damn
well right nobody no one in that city is
coming to help him Rudy Giuliani has not
taken over again unfortunately I think
he's like to probably if he he was a
little younger but nobody's going to
save them there and by the way the mayor
is not the person that can save you
because it has to come from the federal
government from stopping these people
coming in the first place but New York
city is in an absolute free fall I also
love how the host on Fox the guy says
on the side you heard the guy goes
from the she's like we're on we're
on TV please everyone calm down the
cities being overrun uh zombie
apocalypse would you watch your language
foreign
[Music]